make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our series on
too powerful for Marvel movies I know a
lot of you guys are kind of looking at
this and you're like but he's already in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but bear
with me here so for me when I look at
the mobile cinematic universe because
Netflix and the movies are so far
removed from each other um I don't
really even consider Netflix released
what was the Netflix series to be part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe anymore
because they never really reference
anything that went on the closest we
ever got was the incident which was
Avengers 1 and like that's it it's just
there they're almost like heritage a
feature or I'm sorry shows that feature
Marvel characters and don't really take
place in the MCU but kind of do at the
same time so honestly I'm gonna remove
the TV arm here and I'm gonna focus
strictly on the movies and I think the
purple man is too powerful for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and here's why
so when it comes to zebediah killgrave
the way we saw him and really unlike the
TV show was was very different from what
were the way we saw him in the comics
right in the TV show he was more of a
tragic character and it was actually
kind of cool I would even say it was bad
I would say the way that he was depicted
in the show was more interesting in the
way he was depicted in the comics now
that's because of the fact that in the
comic books he's never really written in
a dynamic way well he's never really
written in like a comprehensive
complicated interesting way he's just a
dick right he just does like what what
bad guys do and like that's it he's a
guy he was just granted the ability to
control other people and he does like
terrible terrible things um but in the
show it actually made him kind of
trackabout because he was a victim of
experimentation from his parents and so
um you know again kinda removing that
and focusing more on the comic book
version but kilgrave is a horrible human
being
he's a terrible person why he received
his powers and he was doused with
chemicals and and basically it allowed
him one it turned purple and two it
allowed him to emit pheromones that
dominate the wills of others now the
funny thing about this is that it's not
an absolute guarantee but for a lot of
the Avengers it kind of is right so so
the reason why I would say kilgrave is
too powerful for the MCU is because all
it would take is zebediah killgrave
walking into avengers mansion and saying
avengers and they would all just kind of
listen and just like kill yourselves
like that's that's literally
he would have to do The Incredible Hulk
would be the exception and and kind of
but not really we can't really look to
the purple man in order to determine
that there are a couple ways that we can
sort of figure weaknesses
for example during a Brian Michael
Bendis is opening run his inaugural run
on New Avengers back in 2006 or
something like that there was a story
called the raft and the Wrath was the
first arc he wrote and it dealt with
will really was kind of a lead-up to
Secret Invasion right so like Elektra um
the female assassin chick um she was
actually a scroll like masquerading as a
as a hero but she contracted the villain
electro to basically go into the raft
which was a superhuman prison designed
to hold you know various super-powered
villains and then shut down power to
which freed all the villains across the
board and it was a way to kind of
distract the Avengers in order for the
scrolls to Cannavale can continue
implementing their secret invasion plans
without the avengers really figure out
what was going on because they were
focused on you know I guess a whole host
of other things but during this whole
event you ended up having Luke Cage
right like Luke Cage who at the time was
you know the father of Jessica Jones
daughter and you know marry all of us
are married to Jessica Jones but they
were basically a family violence battle
state has a measurement that were
essentially married and the the you know
because of the fact that kilgrave knew
that and because they'd had dealings in
the past kilgrave tried to seize control
of Luke Cage and Luke Cage managed to
overpower killgrave just by like sheer
force of will but not everyone can do
that and I think that's really the only
instance we've seen someone do that now
in terms of other people who can resist
kilgrave Wolverine can probably do it
and so can the Incredible Hulk and the
reason why we say that is because we
look at characters like Spider Woman
Jessica drew right like Spider Woman has
the ability to emit pheromones that
basically make guys like attracted to
her and so because of that she didn't
kind of like bend them to her will to a
degree not really on the same level as
killgrave she can't like I mean she
can't really emit pheromones and then
say Captain America go kill all the
Avengers I mean I don't know why she
would want to you but as far as I'm
aware of her powers aren't that extreme
but she can kind of you know get them
and kind of coax them into doing things
they would
dude there was one point when she tried
to use her powers on more rain and he
got dizzy right like it didn't work and
he got dizzy so all that happened as his
healing factor started like fighting
against these pheromones because they're
literally like foreign bodies that enter
into his body and then his healing
factor tries to kill it right so it's
like catching a cold a flu or something
like that
The Incredible Hulk of course we know
has a healing factor anyone with a
healing factor should be able to resist
kilgrave right so kilograms being able
to walk in to the two Avengers mansion
and then say Avengers kill yourselves
and like the Incredible Hulk
following suit probably wouldn't happen
but he could do it if it were Bruce
Banner now the question is if he walked
in and did that where the Incredible
Hulk emerged in response to that or
would Bruce Banner successfully manage
to take himself out but that but let
someone like kilgrave having powers like
that in in such a way make him
exceedingly dangerous because he could
walk into something like a nuclear silo
and or or walk into like you know like
the Mitel the atella president uh to
bring together like that office of the
joint like bring all the Joint Chiefs
together and then just say like like
everybody needs to launch the nuclear
war like the entire nuclear arsenal of
the United States and launch it at all
the major US cities in the u.s. like
literally obliterate the country using
the government against itself I mean
like having the ability to dominate the
wills of others by using pheromones in a
way that's that's virtually unrivaled is
a huge amount of power but there are a
couple out spirit if we leave out
healing factors right we leave it up
will rain we leave out the Incredible
Hulk we can actually look to telepaths
but you look to somebody like like Jean
Grey or we can look to somebody like
like Charles Xavier not only that we can
also look at the nature of kilgrave's
powers so because the fact that kilgrave
is basically like emitting pheromones
it's like allergies right if you have
allergies and you go into a place that's
like rife with pollen well of course
your allergies are gonna go nuts but if
you leave them
it's not so full of pollen your
allergies will calm down and that's the
way is healed at that's the way his
pheromones work if you are in the direct
vicinity of kilgrave and then you in
turn like he tells you to do things in
his pheromones of hitting you full blast
you're probably not going to be able to
resist but the further away you are and
the longer you're away the less control
he has over you the question though the
issue is how much damage can he do
during that time when he's in your
vicinity but we also saw and like really
in his original introduction um in the
old Jessica Jones novel Mac series by
Brian Michael Bendis that when when
Jessica Jones went through the whole
story about meeting killgrave and how he
made her do things that she'd want to do
some pretty so pretty terrible things if
you ever go check it out it's pretty
screwed up the kind of stuff he made her
do on to herself and and do him and
things that he made her do with like
other women and so on it's it's pretty
dark and twisted but um when when when
all that story was kind of revealed and
then like she basically had to face him
again
really he kind of lured around wouldn't
it up happening here is Jean Grey of the
x-men showed up and put mental blocks in
place so that when he trying to use his
powers on her they wouldn't work so
someone who is a sufficient telepath can
block the really block like the
pheromones from affecting them now how
that translates I'm not 100% sure
because as far as I'm aware mental
blocks only affect like mentally hatch
right so they don't have like a physical
form there's something putting mental
blocks in their places like they're
putting mental blocks in here in your
mind is like putting a block in your
throat you can't breathe it's not like
that you know I'm not really sure I'm
not aware that it's the case the only
thing that I can I can figure it's
pretty mental blocks in place but
basically print protect the sinuses in
the brain from being affected by the
pheromones and so it just it's almost
like just kind of kind of providing like
a like an immune system for your mind
against like the pheromones of purple
man um but again you know barring
something like that which we don't have
telepaths in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yet we have a couple people we
only have the Incredible Hulk with a
healing factor but the Incredible Hulk
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is much
weaker than this comic counterpart
and so you're talking about a scenario
where the purple man could essentially
walk in to almost any situation and just
bring the world to the brink of war I
just do like what they did in Terminator
and just be like launch our missiles at
Russia and just instigate a world war
like a nuclear world war because he
wants to I mean having that kind of
power being able to like dominate the
world just by issuing a command it's
huge and it's and that's kind of a funny
thing I always say purple man's powers
are wildly unappreciated and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and I never
understood why he was a TV show villain
the purple man is easily like a movie
though like he's easily a movie right
like like being able to go in there and
like the New Avengers like just dominate
all of them that's a huge deal
right I mean that's that's a pretty
significant thing and even if it's not
just them like the x-men right I just
pulling the strings and making the x-men
do things it's a pretty there's a pretty
cool set of powers and kind of a big
deal so I don't know I mean I realize we
might be kind of cooking the books a bit
on this one kind of fudging the numbers
but I think it works um but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explain and make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later
[Music]
you